notre collègue gérard longuet pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur blanc
caire absent au rapport à l'occasion
d'une réforme du baccalauréat qui n'est
pas sans intérêt le ministre bancaire a
découvert une vieille loi humaine
que les parents et les professeurs
maîtrise parfaitement et que les élèves
applique c'est la loi du moindre effort
et à partir du moment où pour les
carrières scientifiques
les mathématiques n'était plus
nécessaire n'était plus obligatoire
il était nécessaire pour les élèves de
ne pas prendre le risque des
mathématiques qui demande un effort et
qui demande une compétence alors je
dirai tout pécheur miséricorde même dans
une enceinte laïque à tout pécheur
miséricorde puisque le ministre blanc
caire a fait machine arrière mais il ne
s'attaque pas aux vrais problèmes de la
dégradation de l'enseignement des
mathématiques dans notre pays tel que
les établit d'ailleurs la commission des
finances à partir de trois réalité
madame pour lesquelles je souhaiterais
avoir un début de réponse premièrement
les professeurs des écoles sont à 80 %
issus des carrières des filières
littéraires
ils ne sont pas à l'aise elles ne sont
pas à l'aise dans cette discipline
deuxièmement là où il ya des professeurs
de mathématiques c'est à dire dans les
collèges et dans les lycées nous avons
un vivier d'étudiants qui est
insuffisant et nous peinons à recruter
parce qu'il est à la concurrence très
forte des carrières d'ingénieur ou des
carrière d'informaticien et vous n'osez
pas vous attaquer à ce problème car
quand on aime quand on veut la qualité
il faut la payer j'ajoute enfin et
dernier et cerise sur le gâteau que vous
avez développé un système de sélection
pour les lycées et les classes
préparatoires et peut-être demain pour
les grandes écoles qui ne repose pas sur
la qualité intellectuelle sur le mérite
colère et sur les résultats mais sur un
ensemble de critères propres à
décourager tout bon lycéens
on vous répondre la parole est au
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et de l'engagement
madame sarah et la syrie il avait la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur longuet ce qui est certain
c'est que les mathématiques sont
absolument
essentielles
mais dans la vie de chaque citoyen et
nous le partageons mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs c'est essentiel pour
l'avenir scientifique de notre pays pour
notre technologie pour l'industrie est
sûre ça nous sommes bien d'accord mais
depuis bien trop longtemps les mâles et
les maths dans notre pays vivent un
déclin et c'est pourquoi jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
dès son arrivée a pris un peu à bras le
corps cette problématique avec la
volonté d'augmenter le niveau général
le niveau général des élèves approfondir
les études scientifiques bien sûr et
monsieur le sénateur vous m'avez posé
une question extrêmement clair comment
d'abord avec le plan mathématique a été
lancé dès 2018 ensuite il a été étendu
avec une formation continue des
professeurs puisque vous m'avez demandé
monsieur le sénateur comment
des référents mathématiques des guides
des ressources un programme clarifier
également depuis la maternelle et jeu et
jusqu'en sixième ensuite monsieur le
sénateur il ya les évaluations
nationales qui permet d'avoir une idée
extrêmement précises parce qu'il ne faut
pas mettre de poussière sous le tapis
une et une évaluation précise du niveau
évidemment les classes dédoublées vous
les connaissez et c'est un long chemin
qui est engagée c'est vrai mais dans son
long dans ce long chemin monsieur le
sénateur il reste aujourd'hui une
augmentation du nombre d'or dans le
cadre de cette réforme des lycées
puisque quand on choisi la spécialité
mathématiques on passe de 8 heures à 9
heures et en réalité on a quand même un
peu plus de monde puisqu'on passe de 49
mille élèves à plus de 51 mille élèves
qui choisissent cette option et pour
aller chercher ce goût ce goût de la
passion et de l'engagement pour les
mathématiques il y a finalement une
nouveauté celle des licences science à
l'humanité pour recréer de activité dans
le monde scientifique dans les
mathématiques monsieur monsieur le
sénateur vous savez le ministère reste
extrêmement ouvert à des aménagements
futurs aussi et des consultations sont
ouvertes parce que l'objectif il est
l'un accompagner les élèves accompagnés
la force de notre pays en renforçant
l'enseignement des mathématiques
la parole du bka le truc